j'ai peur professeur dumbledore
on a tous alors de quelque chose merde
c'est tabou c'est inhabituel
donc ce que monsieur dragon's redoute
par dessus tout c'est de devoir
travailler dans un bureau
monsieur à lézinnes en berne
oui
la magie s'épanouit seulement chez des
êtres d'exception aux tanks devant nous
terrer dans l'ombre mais les usages
anciens et nous conviennent plus
je suppose que vous avez eu vent des
rumeurs grindelwald a une vision
gc fut régné en maître sur le monde des
sorciers et vous solliciter mon aide
pour le pourchasser je ne peux pas m'en
prendre à grindelwald
il faut que ce soit vous à votre place
je refuserais probablement moi aussi il
est à mon sens on en perd gros
pause sous-estimé vos talents monsieur
dragone
leur arrogance est la clé de notre
victoire
les moldus ne sont pas inférieurs
[Musique]
ne sont pas pas signifiante
tu es trop bon hors pair il n'y a pas un
monstre qu'elle tu ne tache pas
croyances
monsieur dragonne croyez-vous que
dumbledore pleurera votre perte
[Musique]
cette photo non je suis bien vivant mais
je suis un alchimiste et par conséquent
immortel au nicolas flamel jeu coop
comme au ski or on vous donne plein 375
ans